and together this contact group has made
it clear
that we will support Ukraine's fight for
freedom
over the Long Haul
and help Ukraine hold and Advance during
the Spring counter-offensive
with unity
and urgency
we will again deliver the support that
we have promised to Ukraine
Ukraine has urgent requirements to help
it
help it meet this crucial moment in the
course of the war and president
zielinski underscored Ukraine's need for
more equipment at our last meeting in
Ramstein
so we're fortunate to be joined Again by
my good friend Ukrainian minister of
defense
Alexi resnikov and Alexi thanks for your
leadership and for joining us again
today in person
but Kremlin is still betting that it can
wait us out
but one year on we are as United as ever
and that shared resolve will help
sustain Ukraine's momentum in The
crucial weeks ahead
and help Ukraine travel the challenging
road that lies Beyond
and looking around this room today
I know that our Unity will only grow
we all understand the stakes in Russia's
war of choice
this isn't just about Ukraine's right to
live in peace and security
it's also about the kind of world that
our children will inherit
none of us want to live in a world where
autocrats can can assault their peaceful
Neighbors
trample their borders and bombard their
people
so we've come together to stand up for a
world where rules matter
where sovereignty is respected and where
civilians are protected next week we
mark
the one the first year of uh the
terrible war in Ukraine the full-fledged
Invasion by Russia against Ukraine and
we see no signs that the President Putin
is preparing for peace what we see is
the opposite he is preparing for more
war so yes the type of support has
involved and and and and that's part of
the ongoing consultations
among allies within NATO within the
Ukraine support group and and it will
continue because we need to need to
ensure that Ukraine
um gets the weapons it needs to be able
to
retake territory Liberate the lands and
win this war and Prevail as a sovereign
independent nation
is
foreign